mais j'ai rarement plus n'a pas la
conscience tout à fait 33
on allait voir
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle rouler au
pas monsieur l'a roulé au pas c'est
marcher un peu comme comme ça enfin fait
moins bien
alors là vous rouler au pas
un peu pourquoi ou le temps on pas alors
faire épater les filles
qu'appelle-t-on un doctorat bon et d'un
doctorat bon c'est un docteur boom qui
serait bon à la tête d'une ville ou d'un
pays
bon qui seraient prises dans la
république comme le docteur schweitzer
alors le docteur choisir ou au gabon je
pense et ça c'est un doctorat parce que
c'est le docteur schweitzer qui est le
patron ben oui mais bon qui serait à la
tête de ce pays ou encore maintenant oui
je pense oui et c'est quel pays vous
m'avez dit le gabon à votre avis
l'hexagone qu'est ce que c'est c'est
donc deux côtés un quoi un oncle du côté
de côté oui vous êtes sur wii
comment imaginez-vous le front national
le fonds national bon verre dégarnis sur
le dessus bien en arrière
quelques ridules petit pour donner l'air
un peu soucieux un petit béret site
ouais je vois pas d'autre chose
le 14 juillet ça vous dit quelque chose
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le 14 juillet
ça a été la fin de la guerre 39 45
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le 14 juillet 4g en
fait
ce qui s'est passé à bastille day avec
les syndicats fo cgt tout ça et qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait ce jour là ils ont
manifesté pour avoir un accord un accord
de coin un accord avec le patronat tout
ça si je vous parle du carré de
l'hypothénuse
chez proverbe un fromage d'auvergne le
carré de l'hypothénuse
à votre avis je crois que c'est un
promoteur je crois que non
enfin quand je vous en parle on me dit
quelque chose quand même oui oui mais
moi je vais t'en a ouvert le militaire
lui parler je vous dis allergologues
rigologue je pense que ça se rapproche à
google docs se rapproche de gogol qui
veut dire quoi
un peu bêtes et on le dit dans quelles
circonstances
quand on voit quelqu'un qui est qui et
pas très futé en fait on dit quoi
hilaire google ou de golog se posent ils
allergologue ouais mais vous vous diriez
plus tant google google que golog vrai
qu'est ce que c'est que la table de
logar
c'est une table qui remplace
trois quatre musiciens des fois et
qu'est ce qu'on trouve sur cette table
plusieurs définitions de chansons comme
me donner un exemple la la la la
contacts sont pour aulas je ne sais pas
- c'est des joueurs comme ça quoi vous
allez le savoir quand même oui moi je
sais pas ce que j'en ai vu mais on en
avait vu ou des tables de logarithmes
surtout dans les orchestres qui servent
de tout ça ouais enfin pour moi que j'ai
vu il a peut-être autre parent ou s'il
ya des tas de logarithmes peut-être
mathématiques ou des trucs comme ça
notre nom pour pas de table de logan
marié mat sur ces surtemps non non voyez
vous c'est qu'elle bassin méditerranéen
où il passe un militant mais moi j'aime
bien les femmes qui sont bien en chair
bien dans leur bien dans leur peau bien
quand le cul un peu gros voiliers le le
cul pas si vous parlez ce point c'est
pour pallier un mot trivial et le bassin
parisien alors ce serait quoi
ben ça serait plutôt des femmes qui ont
les hanches plus minces à votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'un oiseau migrateur nos
opérateurs c'est un enjeu qui va de pays
en pays en temps ils rentrent
l'interprétation nouveau tuerie pays
dans la terre alors pourquoi migrateurs
migrateurs gratteur pour ce qui grattent
la terre et je me gratte
migrateurs migrateurs mon gratteur se
dire qu'ils grattent la terre et il a
admis migrateurs et la demie piqueurs et
pourquoi piqueur non plus que cassano
pour moi pour prendre la nourriture dans
la terre et gratteur gratteur c'est
aussi pour autres sénateurs dans la
terre alors il est migrateurs voilà me
bicoeur un nid quoi migrateurs unis ficr
dans un crime gabelle temps le mobile
celui qui peut bouger par opposition à
quoi l'on a chez lui qui est mort qui
peut pas bouger et qui serait quoi lui
la victime ayant le mobile c'est le
tueur
pourquoi et puisqu'il peut boullier que
lens et moi si je vous dis ça donne ça
tombe à sa double c'est peut être cette
hausse à 12 ses dépens la grandeur du so
nice au bas du dos du seau d'eau pas du
sodome plus tôt dudus aux dom
il se nomme alors sodome qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un assaut en métal donc qui
est prévu justement généralement pour
être employés par un homme papa par une
femme neuf enfants
mais si je vous parle de ça ou alors ça
donne ça dépend parce que
sa dose ça peut être ça c'est peut être
ça ça se demande à quoi la quantité
quand ils aient de quoi
d'où le rapport à quoi la grandeur du ce
sur quoi nous sommes dues tu sodome vous
avez entendu parler de cette expression
la langue de shakespeare ouija dernier
mais pourquoi dit-on la langue de
shakespeare
je sais qu'il buvait trop qui ça
j'espère qu'ils vont à vétroz
et alors alors on comprenait pas ce
qu'ils lisaient par mois et moi j'ai eu
tous ces débats presque disco du premier
jusqu'au 6e et après j'avais été
jusqu'au sixième livre j'allais dire
jusqu'au sixième livre après j'ai arrêté
près ce que j'écrivais on ne comprend
pas ce qu'il disait
parce qu'à cause de sa longue après quoi
sa compagne parce que l'enquêté comme un
bleu un peu bleus et qui est un peu
normal à la cause de la boisson
et puis c'est tout arrêter j'ai eu entre
autres les autres personnes qui buvaient
moins un point ce soir
si je vous dis chantons sous la pluie
labourage est pas tout si je vous dis
chantons sous la pluie
je ne sais pas chanter mais je sais
faire un point labourage et pâturage sur
les mamelles est le fruit de la terre
cela vaut mieux faire l'amour que faire
la guerre et détruire tout le monde et
chantons sous la pluie
hélas les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
vous essayez de parler de chantons sous
la pluie il faut épouser son siège
non mais chantons sous la pluie ça vous
dit rien non il ne peut pas en ce moment
parce que il fait beau temps gris et un
petit brouillage ah non ça ne vous dit
rien gendron ne dit rien non mais vous
irez de terre dans l'espace vous donnera
la possibilité de créer en s'en va on
s'en va en sens quels documents
accablants moralité chers
téléspectateurs si vous apercevez
l'ignoble barbu déborde dans la rue
gambetta micro changer immédiatement
trop tôt et puisque